the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi everybody you're in 507 and if you
look at your syllabus you'll find one of
the things in the front page of your
syllabus is called a lexicon and I'd
like to introduce you to why we've
chosen to have a lexicon for this course
so if you look at this particular slide
or overhead this is what John is going
to teach you this semester introductory
metabolism the glycolysis pathway fatty
acid biosynthesis fatty acid oxidation
meno acid metabolism a complete jungle
how are you ever gonna learn anything
out of this mess
well it's that's actually exactly the
point so what we're gonna do over the
course of the semester is convince you
that all of this mess can be simplified
to ten basic reactions and those ten
basic reactions are what's in the
lexicon so it turns out all of
biochemistry for primary metabolism can
be described using ten different sets of
reactions and vitam your vitamin bottle
and so if you look at your vitamin
bottle what do you see
most of you probably take vitamins you
have vitamin b1 vitamin b2 vitamin b3
vitamin b6 vitamin all of those provide
enzymes the catalysts for all the
reactions and these this complex
metabolic pathway I showed you on the
previous slide they expand the
repertoire of reactions that enzymes can
actually catalyze and so within the
lexicon what we're going to show you is
the chemistry of actually how
these vitamins work so again if we come
back to the lexicon we'll talk about how
carbon carbon bonds are made and broken
and fatty acid metabolism sugar
metabolism will talk about oxidation
reduction reactions and the vitamins
that are used for that transformation
we'll talk about the energy storage and
the energy currency in the cell ATP etc
so what the lexicon is meant to do is
sort of be an aid when you can't
remember what does oxidation and
reduction you can go back to your
lexicon and look up what are the redox
cofactors that are involved in
transformation and by practicing the
chemistry in the first part of the
semester of all these reactions
metabolism should be very
straightforward in terms of all the
connectivities so what hopefully what
you will do is look through your lexicon
tonight see what these reactions are and
then keep it by your side during the
rest of the semester and when you're
having trouble understanding some
chemical transformation you can use the
lexicon as a guide to think about the
chemical transformations that you'll be
looking at over the course of this
semester